Das ist wirklich ein riesenproblem und bedroht unser leben vor allem, wenn wir ins krankenhaus kommen mittlerweile sind unsere schärfsten waffen gegen bakterielle krankheitserreger
Quasi, wirkungslos
Denn es gibt immer mehr
Resistenzen und gängige antibiotika kommen selbst gegen die harmlosen infekten nicht mehr an eine wirklich dramatische entwicklung und die uhr tickt
Forschungsteams weltweit suchen, wie wild nach neuen wirkstoffen ein mögliches hilfsmittel
Algorithmen, die wie viel versprechende moleküle identifizieren ist
Das eine vision oder kann das wirklich funktionieren jetzt, den krieg zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Penicillin das durch schimmelpilze produziert wird galt lange als das allheilmittel
Gegen bakterielle infektion entdeckt wurde ist von alexander flemming und zwar durch bloßen zufall und auch heute noch produziert die natur
Unzählige wirkstoffe die uns in der medizin von großem nutzen sein könnten doch solche neuen vielversprechenden
Mittel wollen entdeckt werden und das ist tatsächlich
Vergleichbar mit der suche nach der nadel im heuhaufen, aber es gibt einen lichtblick vermehrt werden
Bei, der suche jetzt auch algorithmen eingesetzt
Die molekül varianten in den riesigen datenbanken durchgehen und mit bereits erfassten naturstoffen abgleichen und die uhr tickt
Inzwischen haben sich resistenzen gegen alle gängigen
Antibiotika fast entwickelt selbst gegen einfache infekte kommen sie nicht mehr an
Höchste zeit also schnell und effektiv neue wirkstoffe gegen bakterielle erreger zu identifizieren
Aber so leicht ist das nicht spezielle datenbanken können helfen, hier sind neue naturstoffe zu finden und zwar ganz konkret mit ihren
massenspektrometrischen signaturen heißt so viel wie
Aufgeschlüsselt werden die charakteristischen daten die ein massenspektrometer
Identifiziert hat beispielsweise die atom masse sowie die bindungsenergie
Der nucleus ein beispiel für solch eine datenbank ist das global natural products social
Die mps netzwerk für viele experten eine goldmine um neue bioaktive substanzen zu entdecken große hoffnung setzen
forschungsteams weltweit in sogenannte
Peptid naturprodukte pnp es diese sind wohl wirklich vielversprechenden kandidaten für neue
Antibiotika konkret handelt es sich um moleküle die aus vielen proteinen
Bausteinen aufgebaut sind und genau hier ist das problem, denn sie gibt es in unfassbar vielen verschiedenen varianten
Und die meisten von ihnen sind eben nicht ansatzweise in datenbanken erfasst
Doch, jetzt hat ein forschungsteam von der universität sankt petersburg einen lösungsansatz gefunden
Und das ist wirklich entscheidend die
Wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler haben einen neuen algorithmus entwickelt der in der lage ist aus
Der struktur, der bereits erfassten moleküle auf weitere mögliche varianten zu schließen, das system namens
West ermittelt, also?
Welche war es noch geben könnte und zudem auch wie wahrscheinlich deren?
Existenz tatsächlich ist und der algorithmus hat wirklich was drauf im ersten test identifizierte
Er fast zehnmal mehr varianten vom vertrieb naturprodukten als herkömmliche computer verfahren zudem arbeitet
Das programm deutlich schneller für die analyse brauchte der algorithmus wenige stunden andere
Bislang, genutzte programme hätten dafür also für dieses ergebnis
100 jahre gebraucht dazu einer der beteiligten forscher alexej kovac
Damit gibt uns unsere methode einen ganz neuen einblick in die dunkle materie der pnp
Und dies ist nur ein kleiner ausschnitt aus den vielen fortschritten, der big data und ki im medizinischen bereich
Also, keine der künstlichen intelligenz, wir haben ja hier schon mal darüber berichtet
Der nächste schritt ist software die aus daten lernt und sich so selbst weiterentwickelt
Das will sich beispielsweise das forschungsteam von microsoft in seinem projekt hannover zu nutze machen, die idee
Computer sollen sich zunächst einmal, das komplette medizinische wissen aneignen im nächsten schritt sollen, die ärzte teams dabei
unterstützt werden personalisierte
Behandlungsmethoden zu finden, denn sie könnten für jeden einzelnen patienten individuell angepasste
Medikamentencocktails finden statt einen wirkstoff nach dem anderen zu testen könnten
Könnte intelligente software auf grundlage der genomischen daten der patienten die literatur nach der perfekten medikamentenkombination
Durchsuchen auf einen schlag können so tausende von kombinationen an
Also sie analysiert werden und dem ärzte-team vorgeschlagen werden doch die zusammenarbeit
Mit dem menschen könnten die maschinen dann sogar immer weiter dazulernen und ihre intelligenz
Ausbauen, aber auch andere tech giganten, wie amazon apple google oder facebook
investieren
in neues personal aus den bereichen biologie
medizin und chemie
Das ist ein riesengeschäft und sie öffnen komplett neue abteilungen zusammen mit software experten
Sollen sie die großen rechenaufgaben lösen
Die rechenaufgabe deren ergebnis am ende die biologie entschlüsselt und uns krankheiten von grund auf erstehen lässt
Das ist die große vision, die medizinische
Datenverarbeitung dient als grundpfeiler dieser logik
Die instrumente künstliche intelligenz und die analyse und auswertung riesiger datenmengen innerhalb kürzester zeit das ergebnis
zellfunktionen verstehen genome
Kostengünstig sequenzieren und schnell und effektiv neue medikamente entwickeln wir stehen
Also vor einer medizinischen computer revolution
Wenn er als erstes dazu und zu allen anderen themen neues erfahren wollt, dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an
Dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video eben vorab von mir garantiert
Ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion vom krieg zum nicht mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder an
Umfragen teilnehmen und entscheidungen somit treffen, der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau glocke vergessen, hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Resistente bakterien bedrohen, die menschheit ansonsten, bis dann
Bleibt dran?